can humans and machines agree on the
best movies of all time let's find out
while there is debate as to which film
from Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings
trilogy is the best The Return of the
King certainly ended the series with a
bang it announced numerous Awards and
was a huge success of the 76th Academy
Awards winning in all 11 categories that
it was nominated for this book sits on
par with both Titanic and Ben Hur as the
most celebrated films at the Oscars at
the box office a movie grossed 1.1
billion dollars and was the highest
earning film in the franchise this
adaptation of J.R.R tolkien's fantasy
series focuses on the continued efforts
of the surviving members of The
Fellowship of the Ring in their battle
against Sauron and his armies Frodo and
Sam work with Gollum to try and find a
way into Mordor while Gandalf and
Aragorn lead the defense of gondor's
capital ministereth while admitting the
final chapters of the original book the
film memorably depicts the destruction
of the One Ring the final defeat of
Sauron and the departure of several
important figures from Middle Earth
perhaps the most visually impressive and
audacious film of the trilogy The Return
of the King received near reversal
critical Acclaim and it concludes what
many consider to be the best movie
trilogy in history this makes it an easy
choice for charge gpt's last spot on his
AI generated top 10.
having AI rank all of the Star Wars
movies and doesn't leave us see the
films in the original trilogy score very
high while there has been plenty of
discourse as to which of the initial
three films in the franchise would come
out on top the first entry makes a
strong case after all A New Hope was not
only a groundbreaking experience in
terms of special effects and science
fiction storytelling it also sets up an
entire expanded universe of novels
Comics games and TV shows well that's
the real trick isn't it despite the
futuristic setting a new hope is very
much a classic good versus evil story as
Luke Skywalker Princess Leia on solo and
Obi-Wan Kenobi battle against the
Galactic Empire led by Darth Vader and
grandmother Tarkin Luke begins his
journey to become a Jedi master using a
mystical power known as the force and
later joins a rebel alliance to destroy
the Empire's Death Star A New Hope has
been recognized many times for its
importance in cinema it has been added
to the National film registry but a
Library of Congress and the soundtrack
is considered one of the most important
in movie history
Forrest Gump is a 1994 movie based on
Winston groom's novel of the same name
it follows the life of an Alabama man
who tells his life story to a variety of
strangers from a park bench the film has
an inauspicious start but the audience
soon learns how Forrest Gump is a war
hero a world-class table tennis player
and a renowned Runner who inadvertently
influences events across modern American
history he has a lifelong crush on his
childhood friend Jenny and he makes
friends with memorable characters like
Benjamin Buford Bubba blue and
Lieutenant Dan all before opening a
shrimp business that makes him a
millionaire or the story is memorable
the film's inclusion on chat gpt's top
10 is interesting because Forrest Gump
has his fair share of detractors with
many criticizing the film's portrayal of
American History still it was an instant
success earning 678 million dollars
against a budget of just 55 million
dollars it was also a hit on the awards
circuit winning six Academy Awards
including best picture best director and
best actor the reach of Forrest Gump is
even extended into everyday vocabulary
with phrases such as life is like a box
of chocolates becoming known worldwide a
cultural Legacy that judge GPT seems to
have identified
12 Angry Men is one of the oldest films
picked by chat GPT that's the vast
majority of the entries came in the last
few decades this courtroom drama
directed by Sydney lamez in his feature
film debut hit movie theaters in 1957
and was based on Reginald Rose's
teleplay starring Henry Fonda Lee J Cobb
and Ed Begley the action focuses on a
jury deliberating whether to find a
teenager guilty of murder as the group
finds little to agree upon and fails to
reach a unanimous decision each begins
to question the evidence more carefully
while being forced to examine their
personal morals and preconceived ideas
immediately upon released 12 Angry Men
was acclaimed by critics and today it
holds a perfect 100 approval rating on
Rotten Tomatoes yes the film did
surprisingly poorly at the box office
something that has been attributed to
the fact that it was a black and white
movie released at a time when widescreen
color pictures were becoming more common
it also found a little Awards success
despite several nominations I don't
understand you people I mean all these
picky little pony keep bringing up they
don't mean nothing none of that has
stopped's 12 Angry Men from being widely
considered among the very best movies
ever released preserved in the National
film registry by the Library of Congress
it has been loaded for his perfect drama
the Striking use of camera angles and a
tight scripts that never feels like it
outlasts its welcome
it's not very surprising that shot GPT
chosen this list among the 10 best films
of all time it is widely seen as a
masterpiece of modern Cinema and one of
director Steven Spielberg's most
important movies High Praise indeed
considering his filmography includes
Jaws Saving Private Ryan and E.T the
Extraterrestrial the 1993 historical
drama tells the story of a German
industrialist who manages to save
countless Jewish refugees from the
clutches of the Nazis during the
Holocaust perpetrated at the height of
World War II Liam Neeson stars as a
titular Oscar Schindler who works to
save the lives of those being persecuted
by employing them at his Factory he is
just one of a star-studded cast that
includes Ben Kingsley Ray fines and
Caroline Goodall all of whom received
critical Acclaim for their performances
bringing in a worldwide gross of 322
million dollars and winning seven
Academy Awards Schindler's List quickly
established itself as a classic with the
American Film Institute putting it at
number eight on its all-time list much
of the film's critical Acclaim was
focused on how it portrayed them hours
of the Holocaust in a way that displayed
the humanity of the victims and those
who fought against it others know to the
authentic realism of the film along with
the visually stunning cinematography
that remains unmatched among other
historical dramas
sequel to 2005's Batman Begins 2008's
The Dark Knight once again sees
Christopher Nolan direct Christian Bale
as the Caped Crusader the ensemble cast
includes Gary Oldman as James Gordon
Michael Kane as Alfred pennyworth and
Aaron Eckhart as Two-Face however the
most notable casting Choice was Heath
Ledger Who provided one of the most
definitive portrayals of the Joker ever
seen on screen the story follows Batman
as he fights back against a chaos The
Joker and flakes on Gotham City noted
for its gritty and ultra realistic take
on Batman compared to the more vibrant
and colorful superhero movies of the
time the dark knight sets a new standard
for all other comic book adaptations
meanwhile Legend's performance was
praised for transforming the character
into a truly terrifying figure that
still Incorporated the villain's
signature grotesque violence and
sardonic humor it's a brilliant film
that earned more than one billion
dollars worldwide and received almost
Universal Acclaim from critics and
audiences alike making it an easy pick
for chat gpt's list
few would argue pulp fictions placed
among the greatest films of all time so
it makes sense that chat GPT has it high
on its top 10. Quentin Tarantino's
second major release follows an ensemble
cast of characters in various
interconnected stories featuring many of
the elements fans became familiar with
in Tarantino movies including non-linear
storytelling and graphic violence Pulp
Fiction was praised for its storytelling
strong performances iconic characters
dense dialogue and Unforgettable
monologues the winner of the Pomodoro
the 1994 can film festival and the
recipient of numerous Oscar nominations
at the 67th Academy Awards Pulp Fiction
was a commercial and critical success
Entertainment Weekly named it the best
film of the last 30 years in 2008 and it
has influenced countless other movies
and television series since its initial
release an undoubted international
phenomenon Pulp Fiction popularized
mainstream actors returning to low
budget Independent films and has had a
long lasting impact on pop culture and I
will strike down upon thee with great
Vengeance and Furious anger this movie
was also incredibly important for many
of its Stars it helps launch the careers
the likes of Samuel Jackson while giving
Bruce Willis a push away from the action
hero stereotype yet developed in Die
Hard most notably though it revitalized
a career of John Travolta who was
floundering before he was cast as
Vincent Vega
anyone who has read a list of greatest
movies ever is familiar with awesome
World Citizen Kane and chat GPT seems
aware enough of the conversation to
place it high on its list it stars Wells
as media Baron Charles Foster Kane and
it follows a newspaper reporter who
attempts to discover the meaning of the
word Rosebud which was uttered on Kane's
deathbed by looking back at his life and
interviewing his friends family and
colleagues what helps Citizen Kane Stand
Out Among the many other great films of
its era is how it's innovated in so many
ways a movie utilizes a storytelling
technique that was unusual for the time
with the action taking place out of
sequence it also employs an unreliable
narrator making it impossible to
completely understand the flawed
anti-hero at the story Center on top of
that Wells used montages to Great
effects and popularize camera techniques
such as deep focus and crane shots these
inventive approaches to filming set new
precedence for what directors could do
in their own projects and were endlessly
copied in Hollywood and the rest of the
world leaving a lasting impression on
Cinema
the Shawshank Redemption is among the
best screen adaptations of Stephen
King's vast catalog of Stories the 1994
film was erected by Frank Darabont and
starred Tim Robbins and Morgan Freeman
as the main characters and the in red
both are inmates at Shawshank State
Penitentiary though Andy maintains his
innocence and secretly plots to escape
and seek refuge in Mexico the story
focuses on Andy's struggles in prison as
he befriends read in attempts to survive
among the violent criminals and corrupt
prison staff despite a positive
reception and success on the awards
circuit the Shawshank Redemption was
something of a box office failure upon
release of course I might have something
to do with the fact that it came out the
same year as Blockbusters like Pulp
Fiction Forrest Gump and speed however
reruns on television and strong video
rental numbers soon made it a popular
film throughout the US it has also
consistently ranked as IMDB's highest
rated film of all time Alyssa holds some
interesting similarities with the one
created by chat GPT regardless a sure
Shank Redemption excels in almost every
front Rob and Freeman's performances are
brilliant while the cinematography
creates an authentic portrayal of the
prison making the viewer feel as trapped
and frustrated as a Prisoners the film
also boasts a subtle soundtrack that
perfectly accompanies the on-screen
action and it tells an uplifting story
that doesn't shy away from depicting the
horrors of life in jail and it's been a
month in the Infirmary
bogs spent a week in the hole Francis
Ford Coppola's 1972 crime film The
Godfather is often cited among the best
examples of Cinema adapted from Mario
puzo's 1969 novel the film features an
accomplished cast composed of Marlon
Brando Al Pacino James Khan Robert
Duvall and Diane Keaton it follows
Michael Corleone's rise to become the
ruthless mafia boss of the Corleone
family after being convinced to join the
family business why the Godfather is so
beloved isn't difficult to understand
Brando and Pacino put in exceptional
performances on Coppola's production
pioneered new camera techniques to
create beautiful and striking shots
characters throughout the film also each
have their own memorable monologues as
part of an almost perfectly written
script at the somber musical score
alongside intense action sequences and
it becomes easy to see how the godfather
has become so highly thought of by
audiences and critics the film was a
landmark entry in the gangster's genre
launched Al Pacino to stardom and
resuscitated Brando's diminishing career
the importance of the movie which has
been preserved in the National film
registry and is ranked second to only
Citizen Kane by the American Film
Institute is hard to overstate charge
GPT seems to appreciate the gravatars of
the godfather has earned over the
decades ending the film the top spots
honest list of the best movies of all
time
[Music]